my first question to you guys is like
what made you decide to move to Japan in
the first place cuz you've been here for
how many years now
I've been here four years now yeah I
guess for you it's more obvious though I
mean yeah cuz I've spent what like half
my life here and I have family up north
and in Tokyo at least with me like I've
said this in videos before but like I
was gonna move to Japan after I
graduated from uni anyway because I I
think this was like back when I had
maybe like 20 K 30 K sobs so I wasn't
doing it full-time at all yeah I was him
like my second year of university and I
was interning at like a Japanese like IT
company which I believe is now like the
funk like it doesn't exist anymore
I don't think so glad that internship
Neverwinter yeah but yeah so I I was
gonna move to Japan anyway because like
it just makes sense for me because I'm
fluent in both English and Japanese
which is such a huge plus here like if
you know both languages like you can
pretty much get a job anyway we'll get
to that
yeah we'll get to that and like no one
in Australia gives a [ __ ] if you can
speak Japanese yeah exactly like my
dad's word said like a Japanese IT
company for 30 years he can't speak a
water Japanese yeah it's cuz no one in
the office can speak Japanese right but
here it's like if you can speak English
you can do business with anybody yeah
you know out of Japan so it just was
like a natural process for me to like
okay I get my paper I work it like some
[ __ ] IT company in Japan and then
yeah it's funny because I I reckon one
of the few industries where Japanese is
it can be super super important is anime
and manga you maxed out your luck there
yeah exactly
so like either way like it was just a
natural like path for me to like move
you yeah but you know instead of you
know doing that desk job that I had sent
my plans on you know YouTube for me blew
up like in my third year Union when I
graduated so yeah it's like alright
guess I'll do you two for as long as I
can and then you're still doing it I'm
still doing it somehow
I'm still doing it I know that's crazy
the story of oh I guess like the the
original plan
was brought up to you guys about thank
you yes like a year ago yeah cuz I
wanted to move here for a while I
remember like since we first met each
other and since my first trip to Japan I
was like I could really see myself
living here this is and this is not like
the typical we've kind of fantasy but
you know I was what like I remember back
in it back in the day when he was like
mid-2000s yeah like the weeaboo dream
was to live in Japan and you know work
in the anime work in the anime industry
it was just like a [ __ ] dream that
nobody had ever proven all you know so
it was just that we dream but I never
really wanted that I was like you know
I'm happy with a normal career yeah I'd
never really fantasize about going to
Japan but I remember the first time I
came here it was so I openin for me cuz
it was like you know when you know that
feeling when you like this country just
works in a lot of ways and it's through
with my job so I'm like this this could
be a really good opportunity for me yeah
I definitely felt the same thing with
how I thought about Japan yeah I I
couldn't have cared less about living
here and I thought people who are
learning the language at the time you
know I was like fifteen fourteen like
that's kind of cringe bro yeah but like
now that you know I've actually start to
learn it I regret it I regret that like
I didn't learn any because I could have
been like a few months ahead at least
right I I wish I was more weeaboo like
now that the cringy we're in phase is
over I wish I was that cringey weeaboo
cuz that would give me so much more
advantage now that you know and and a
part of me which I remember I used to
think that way like anyone who's
learning it it's just like wow so sad
you never like actually gonna learn it
but like to be fair if you're learning
anything you know any other kind of
language especially if you only speak
one I think yeah that's like good good
on you like better yourself you know
like yeah gives a [ __ ] and I really
regret that I thought that everyone
who's learning Japanese because of
animes pathetic like yeah but then again
I was like an edgy teenager right and we
all think that and yeah like like like
you said I have no I no intention or
want to live here yeah I was pretty
content in the UK and even when I
visited you I thought wow this is an
amazing place to come visit
yeah but I don't think I were still sold
yet on moving here cuz I think I don't
what you guys but I really like need
French every week I do need like to have
friends that I like see often otherwise
like I really get like upset
I like the antithesis of everywhere yeah
like I I need to socialize or I really
like a Rudy sauce take a toll on me